yeah who is this
who is this yeah
like i just really like
i love making music and like if
it feels really cool it's like a good
time doja cat just did her best
impression of ariana grande and well
i'll let you decide how good it is like
i
honestly like i don't even
i don't even think about anything else
all i think about is like
music like that's it's my favorite thing
to do
so just a little back story doja cat and
ari have become pretty regular
collaborators
the 25 year old rapper was recently
featured on ari's album positions
on the track motive you treat me like
gold
a trophy oh you baby spoil me baby and
more recently
doja teamed up with ari and megan the
stallion on a remix of 34.35
so it seems pretty safe to say these two
know each other
pretty well and during a recent insta
live
doge approved it i'm gonna do the
impression but i'm gonna do it very
short
i will do my ariana grande impression
but i'm not going deep i'm not going
deep
yeah so dojo took a second to get into
character and
well here you go yeah
don't get don't
get mad hold on
hold on hold on listen
yeah yeah
that's it that's all you're getting
that's all okay so
she isn't wrong
yeah yeah yeah so the ceso singer may
have said she was done
but she wasn't yeah
who is this who is this yeah
like i just really like
i love making music and like if
it feels really cool it's like a good
time like i
honestly like i don't even
i don't even think about anything else
all i think about is like
music and while doja did her best to
channel her inner ari
let's be real no one does an impression
better than ari herself
oh thank you back in 2015 the grammy
winner flexed her impression skills on
the tonight show
including britney spears
oh
aguilera
[Music]
[Applause]
and my personal fave celine dion
[Music]
[Applause]